it is reported that UN staff could be
responsible for 60,000 rapes in a decade
and that 3,300 pedophiles are working in
their aid agencies we help fund that
through our taxes we also help fund such
critical programs as research into the
Tibetan verb how to keep Indian houses
cool during the summer cutting smoking
levels in China and of course everyone's
and Greg's particular favorite Ethiopian
girl band I speak of course of yagna and
we pay for all of this from a large
ring-fenced budget which doesn't get cut
even while critical services at home do
doling out our money just to meet a
target is nonsense and it's not even
clear the heat spinning actually works
our aid model is broken and it is wrong
and this entire scandal stops now and it
stops until we have rigorous audit
trails and there is full accountability
in these charity's accounts well we've
had this discussion on as many numerous
occasions around this type my friend I
mean I I spend quite a lot of time in
Africa working with VSO who I think are
extremely good I meet totally committed
people earning very little money a lot
of the VSO people are volunteers who
virtually nothing and they do great
things and what's happened the last week
must be incredibly incredibly
discouraging to them because the little
old lady worked New York I'm sure and I
totally agree but well I think I do
agree with is that is that we have got
to there needs to be a proper look at
the whole satyr now and because I do
believe the overseas aid I do think it's
I think it's in Britain's interest I
think we are I think we are developed in
the development agencies London is the
centre of the world I think it has a lot
of soft power but I agree with in damage
of quite small stories and I'm very
unpleasant with quite small studies it
is incalculable and therefore we need to
look at the whole sector again and as I
said I think I thought with the Charity
Commission is saying what is the role of
the Charity Commission because I'm not
sure I do know the other thing of course
I
sure there's this corset moment you set
up a charity and someone starts giving
you money you get 20% extra from the
Exchequer yes you know and that's what
that's what people were to why people
visit the charities so they get and they
don't to be it seems to me that no too
many charities set their own
extraordinary you know some and I just
think I believe in development I believe
in the money I just think you've got to
look at it again now this is the reason
you were nodding vigorously as I
outlined this conversation particularly
I came to audit trails and for foreign
aid audit trails and foreign aid my arm
was long enough I would have high five
to over the table I leave a split my
dress or do an injury so what I would
say is I completely agree with you and
this foreign aid whenever I asked on
Twitter what do you want me to do bear
on the pledge they constantly foreign it
I promise you it is relentless foreign
aid for it and I get frustrated with the
foreign aid so I think it's good I think
it's a good thing to help people that
are less fortunate and in need so the
principle of helping others I'm very
comfortable with I'm uncomfortable with
it being enshrined in law so protect
this point seven percent because what I
think happens when you enshrine a
spending target in law you are asking
for wastage you're asking for this last
minute desperation to try and reach this
target and dollar all money and we do
not have audit trails and checks and
balances and I think that we waste so
much money and I also think it's quite
offensive that we will happily slash all
over well not all but much of our at
home spending and protect feels attacked
what we give elsewhere that's wrong I
know you aren't that my Dylan Hartley to
my Owen follow my own feral I know you
support me so I'll come to you last week
I want to bring June him because I could
hear you touching and moaning and
groaning as I went through that well
clearly you two had breakfast again
[Laughter]
first of all you're somebody next that
has been very strong in your views in
terms of immigration and your concerns
around it around immigration and I think
if you are somebody that is concerned
with immigration then actually you
should be in favor of foreign aid
because this is how we keep good
covenant governance and this is how we
create civil society in those countries
so those people don't come over here and
not working that well if you don't care
ladies
well let me finish so but if we weren't
doing anything trust me it would be a
lot worse and as somebody who's worked
extensively in this sector and I've been
on the ground and I've seen the impact
that this Aid has by and large it does
good by and large it provides jobs in
these countries yeah you can you can
close that's all over there you need to
go there and see it better yourself I
think in many ways the way or I think we
should have an aid budget I think in
many ways that way it Spencer is a total
contempt for the British taxpayer you
know the government is chasing
artificial targets with aids that were
they that is that a 40 years out-of-date
we in the past five years have given a
billion pounds to Pakistan which is the
only country as far as I know off the
top of my head that can afford 130
warheads and a space program we are
still funding their poor when they don't
you let me finish there we are still
funding they're there they're starving
people well we shouldn't have to the
trouble was the international that was a
Development Agency is the Nixon it's the
only agency that's never had to
economize and that's never had its
budgets cut and we know they've
mismanaged their budgets and they chuck
money into a void into corrupt
governments into dangerous government
for projects because only 1 billion so
one-tenth of the aid budget is spent on
human ganda and what was interesting
there is that there was a scandal
involving Irish aid money and with 30
million pounds when they're lost missing
in the Prime Minister's office as it was
out defeated the British immediately
withdrew all their aid and so the job
should be more
immediately to the right and they gave
it in state two agencies to spend rather
than government I think that's why quite
like I think you need a review of the
whole thing yes I have no problem with
the money I just want to make sure no
problem with transparency but trust me
if you do what you're suggesting you
might end up with far worse results
anyway I have a quote from the
government right and this is what they
have to say at times of global
instability it's more important than
ever for us to be outward looking and
engaged the UK's development budget is
an important part securing Britain's
place in the world alongside our
world-class diplomatic service two
percent commitment on defense spending
and permanent seat at the UN Security
Council June thank you just to throw a
couple of words back to you Greg you
talked about soft power it helps the UK
with soft power explain in what way what
we get out of it well we're just about
to lose a lot of soft power because in
their home how does anything to do this
little power isn't that bribery so if
you're saying basically I'm gonna give
you some money in order to it's one of
the things it gives yes Britain Britain
is event and well regarded in many
countries softer touch because of the
able you could you could send you could
say it actually gives us influence we
don't give all but we are giving a lot
of it to corrupt governess going
straight into the Treasuries and not to
the cow it's also goes into impact
investment and impact investments builds
infrastructure projects yes that's one
of those days I'm gonna serve the
Emperor and also no no funny country
there a lot of the money goes into
impact investment and what you're doing
is you're helping to build these
economies these then because we've we're
leaving you Europe we need as many
trading partners as possible and what
I'm saying is when you do that you help
build those economies people in no
it's not how was that bribery if you're
going to be trading with me sure you
help keep those people in their
countries rather than coming here and as
a result we have us a much more stable
while people die in hospitals where when
you actually look at how much has been
lost to fraud and all the rest of it
some people are putting this figure it's
300 million a year from example the lost
to corruption and fraud do because
you're there but you may have to accept
that there is a price for foreign aid of
giving foreign aid and helping others
and that some of it will get lost I'm no
doubt about that it knows I have the
same my own experience of a place that I
haven't seen that I've seen projects
that you think didn't work but that's a
different matter there's always gonna be
things that don't work and don't work
they are what you do is get in and get
out as fast as you can if it doesn't
work yeah but but I don't I have not
seen but you object what was working so
I've seen lives change and those things
and that it that's priceless